failure failure failure failure fail
failure failure failure failure failure
give up something to get something and I
thought I didn't have any money so I
have no phone
I painted my windows black so I didn't
know if I was up the Sun was down all I
knew was I had to write and I wrote and
I wrote it's it was very bad it wasn't
good at all but every day it was getting
better and better like like a machine
like a muscle until finally the idea for
rocky came so the idea is you must fail
a hundred times to succeed once it's
that's part of it you know one succeeds
the first time it's learning how to not
get disappointed with failure to
understand failure
you only learn when you fail you don't
learn we used to see earlier too
but we fail that's what you learned so
that's how I learned die lucky I was a
failure in New York and that is the
reason I started writing which may be
successful one of the things that I've
been through as a student was some
leadership training and one of the
things they taught us was to have to not
be afraid of failure you know and
instead have the goal to fail a lot
quickly and then eventually you'll
succeed and I sort of took this to heart
and they'll start a slogan called
healthy disregard for the impossible and
they actually made you write down sort
of the things you would do that were
kind of impossible but you thought you
might really accomplish and that's
really stuck with me and in everything
that I've tried to do and I think you
know it was very very close that we
wouldn't have started the company and I
think there are many of you out there in
sort of similar situations you know do
you want to take a little bit more risk
do you want to try something out and you
know even if you don't succeed we should
actually tried many things that didn't
work you know Google happens to work
pretty well
but there are many things that we did
that didn't but we don't worry about
those right because we we tried many
things so I just encourage you to take a
little more risk in life and I think if
you do it often enough they will really
pay off but through all the occupations
I've had I've experienced successes and
as you know failures I'm asked what it
felt like to lose to President Obama not
as good as winning failures aren't fun
but they are inevitable more importantly
failures don't define who you are
some people measure their life by their
secular successes how high on the
corporate ladder they got how much money
they made did they do better than their
high school classmates if that's the
kind of success you're looking for
you're bound to be disappointed life has
way too much chance and serendipity
to be assured fame or fortune you cannot
achieve success without failure some of
my biggest successes come from some of
my biggest failures in the early 90s
when my friends were graduating from
Howard I got fired from that first job
that I got with Andhra hero I know a lot
of you know this story but some of you
may not know how scared I was
see I was scared to death I didn't have
a degree
my girlfriend was eight and a half
months pregnant with my first baby I
bought a brand-new house in Scarsdale
that I could not afford so I I found
myself sitting alone in my bedroom and
asking myself the question that
sometimes we all ask each other what are
you going to do now what are you gonna
do now you should have kept your mouth
shut
and Sun up and just did what Andre told
you to do but you want to act like you
was making the heat rankings and now
look at [ __ ] what are you gonna do now
so I had two choices either I was going
to sit in that failure and give up well
I was gonna make a decision to step out
of the darkness you see when you're in
that darkness you want to sit there and
wait for the light to come when you're
in that darkness it feels uncomfortable
but you can't wait and sit in that
darkness the only way out is to step
forward to face your fears to become
your own light I had to make a decision
I had to decide to become my own life I
had to believe in myself like never
before I had to find my inner power now
I'm not gonna lie to you there's gonna
be a lot of times y'all about to fail
I'm still failing every day we're we are
all a work in progress and one day
you'll be sitting in the dark like I was
and you're gonna be asking yourself what
am I gonna do now
do you want ask yourself again it's
lower down what I'm gonna do now but in
that moment I want you to remember the
power of you now here's an important
point
nothing works the first time when you
try something new it probably won't work
when you try something new several times
it probably won't work and the turning
point in my life came when I would hear
good ideas and I was so eager to be
successful in selling I would run out
and try the ideas and they wouldn't work
I try a way of getting an appointment or
answering an objection or closing a sale
it wouldn't work and my natural response
ah
and I think yes to be disappointed and
then I realized nothing works at least
the first few times so I decided I would
try a new idea five or ten times before
I pass judgment on I would not just try
it once and quit like most people do and
that changed my whole life it was a
turning point in my life because I
realized from then on if you've got a
good idea and you've got a good goal and
you want to double your income and
improve the quality of your life and you
have to try new things in order to get
new results it's not going to work the
first time so you say well that didn't
work try something else and try
something else and try something else
now if you try only two things can
happen what are they succeed or fail if
you succeed you do more of it if you
fail you learn from it get smarter and
try it again so you cannot lose by
taking action you could only lose by not
taking action failure is a part of the
learning process right what's the risk
of failure what you'll be embarrassed or
risk of failure how do you distinguish
failure from learning uh in your whole
life
you know failure implies that it stopped
that the game stops alright if it's part
of a you're failing and then you learn
then that learning is part of the moving
forward right so that is what the
process is like fail learn move forward
and constantly do that because you're
cutting edge you're going where people
haven't been before in inventiveness I
mean I've got a real belief and this is
a true belief and if those of you
everybody's got kids out there if I ever
hear my kids say the word failure I lock
them in a room for a week and I I would
request if we have any power in this
country that we could take that out of
our English dictionary and replace it
with the word feedback yeah because
that's all failure in our words is isn't
it it's feedback we learn from mistakes
when we have had failures those have
ultimately resulted in some of the
greatest successes we've ever had you
talk about those particularly when
someone comes to see you and they say
yeah feel really bad because this didn't
work out okay well let me tell you about
some other things that didn't work out
that we learned a lot from and you know
let's pick ourselves back up and let's
figure out what what we what we learn
from this
and how we go apply that next time you
know when you're in the zone of doing
things that no one's ever done before if
you're only succeeding you're not taking
enough risk you have bad days and you
know from the outside people may look at
my life and think that everybody is
everything's good all the time and it's
really just not the case
you can have dark days it doesn't matter
how well your career is doing you know
there's all kinds of things happen in
life but as far as creative dreams go
you know I remember we had released the
first song off our second album and it
bombed it did terribly was called attack
and yeah well you should have requested
it on the radio more buddy because
nobody else thought so and you know
maybe there were other forces working at
that time against us but I thought it
was a decent song as well for the time
but it bombed the record company wanted
to drop us they actually did they called
our management said we're dropping the
band and somehow you know they convinced
the the the head of the record minute
Jason Flom the guy was in there to come
and see us one more time at Madison
Square Garden we're opening for
Audioslave and the crowd hated us right
they hated us it was just but it was a
but crowd was largely there it was made
up of Soundgarden and Rage fans a lot of
older people and they just were like who
are these weirdos on stage will they get
out of here but anyway we played that
show and in the president of the record
company who had wanted to drop us he
decided to give us one more shot but
that time was really brutal
you know it's our second album we knew
if we got dropped it would be very
difficult to ever find a way to make
music and share it again this was way
before you know iTunes it was way before
Facebook and it was way before YouTube
as a way before it was so easy to make
and distribute music and share your work
online you know so it was a challenging
time and really dark but I decided to
direct the video myself it was for a
song called the
they released it and it changed our
lives so you know in that that story has
kind of happened more than a few times
in our careers you know and it's
happened to me as an actor it's happened
to me as a director I've looked at
things so many times videos that you
guys see now and think oh that's pretty
good and just wanted to like rip my
eyeballs out it was so bad so I think
the thing that we don't teach each other
and remind each other enough of is that
failure is oftentimes more important
than success and success is the thing
that can actually make us fail it's
really important to note what the
lessons are to learn in failure and it
happens a lot it doesn't feel good but
it's a necessity you know my story back
in 2005 when I was stuck with all these
bad habits and I couldn't make any
changes I kept trying to change them all
at once I would change my entire diet
which diet is actually a series of
habits I would change my entire exercise
routine now and trying to quit smoking
try and be productive and stop
procrastinating wake up early and I
would do all of these at once and I kept
failing I couldn't understand why and it
wasn't really that it was me yeah a lot
of times I would internalize it actually
all the time I would internalized it and
think I had no self-control not
discipline I'm not good enough I'm not
strong and this week and so I just feel
bad about myself and develop this
negative self-image and basically
destroy any trust that I had in myself
but really it wasn't a problem with me
it was a problem with the method and so
what I'm what I'm proposing is instead
of failing over and over at creating a
whole bunch of habits at once or one
really big habit instead of a small and
instead of failing at that change the
method and yeah I mean if you failed
don't keep doing the same thing over and
over you gotta make some changes and so
what I'm proposing is take that failure
as a lesson and adapt your habit change
and be smarter do it do it in a smarter
way so what do you think about failure I
think that the best way to deal with
failure is to focus on why you did the
thing in the first place
so you look at the big picture right
one failure doesn't mean that you've
failed in all and then you look at the
small details of where you could have
improved and next time you do better I
think people get too caught up in
failure failure is gonna be part of the
process if you're doing something big
something new something different you're
gonna fail you fail your way to success
if you have zero failures in your life
is because you're playing life so safe
that you haven't taken any single risk
and so failure it's not this big thing
that you need to avoid it's normal its
natural it's gonna happen and you will
fail your way to success so thank you
guys so much for watching I love to know
what you think of the video leave it in
comments below and continue to believe
and we'll see you soon